The concept of anger,
I think we have to think about the
phases of anger.
There are three phases of anger.
One is somebody provokes me,
I feel angry.
Okay,
I don't have any control over that.
Right?
Then there's the phase of anger of how
do I react to it?
Do I walk away?
Do I respond,
do I punch the guy in the face,
but I call them with something in it.
That's my reaction to anger,
and then the other thing is,
okay,
I didn't have any choice to being
feeling angry when I was provoked.
How long am I going to hold onto that
anger?
An hour a day,
22 years,
right?
So in order to keep things straight,
I give these three phases,
three different names,
the feeling of anger,
I call anger.
The reaction to anger I call rage and
they're hanging onto the anger is called
resentment.
Right?
And then as you clarify and I said,
okay,
I can do nothing about my feeling of
anger other than perhaps take some
things in perspective,
right?
One of my father's teachings that helped
me a great deal was that when somebody
did something to my father,
which should have a provoked anger,
my father would say,
you know,
what he did was so foolish.
If he only knew how fully said was what
he did,
he wouldn't have done it.
So,
you know,
I feel sorry for the person for being
such a fool,
but if she feels sorry for a person,
how can you be angry at him?
Yeah.
I feel pity for him.
Pity and anger girl doesn't go together.
Uh,
but nevertheless,
I can't control how I feel when
provoked,
but I certainly can't control what my
reaction is going to be.
And finally,
how long do I hang on to the resentment.
Like greatest lesson came from
alcoholics anonymous where somebody
said,
harboring your resentment is allowing
someone who you don't like to live
inside your head without paying any
rent.
And I'm not that kind of a guy.
I'm not a nice guy like that to let
somebody else.
Right?
So Aa helped me get rid of resentments.
Uh,
reacting to anger took me awhile to be
able to control my rage and then I had
to realize that this is part of my
being.
Human animals react with rage when,
when provoked,
right?
I as a human being,
am I supposed to be above that and
middle earth and Homo sapiens.
So I learned how to control my anger.
So I think those are.
If a person keeps those things in mind,
right?
And there's some people who feel guilty
for feeling angry,
right?
Especially a parent.
You don't have a choice,
right?
The feeling of anger is loving yourself.
And if you don't have a choice,
there's was a reason to feel guilty
about it.
How you react.
No.
My suggestion is keep an anger journal.
All right,
here's what happened today,
right?
Somebody did this is at,
and here's how I did right.
Then at night,
is it at the time that I'm provoked,
I think it gives them clear because I'm
under pressure to respond,
but at night when I look over what
happened during the daytime and I say
that I handled that in the best way
possible,
could I have done something better and
that becomes a lesson for the next time.
All right,
so I think keeping a journal about anger
and how we respond to it is an excellent
way overnight because ultimately if I am
an raged,
it doesn't hurt the other person as much
as it hurts me.